bientôt c'est squeeze assure t elle se
trouve sur la voie là magicien magicien
c'est un petit jeu de plateforme qui a
l'air plutôt rageant c'est parti alors
je suis cet homme avec son bateau donc
l'unique pouvoir quand va-t-on donne
c'est sauter abraham en voilà un très
gros pouvoir vraiment à même effrayant
et partie par ce chemin de t'approche
pas trop de cette chose
oh non ouais c'est beau c'est sympa le
but est de prendre les clés comme celle
ci est ensuite d'aller à la porte voilà
et ce petit bout sert à rien c'est bien
ce que je pensais pas y critiquait les
tons numéro jeune femme numéro inconnu
surtout qu'ils ont cette coupe nullards
toi par contre le bio ça je garde mon
numéro
alors on doit sauver la princesse whaou
ne pense même pas à sauver la princesse
est la mienne mais tu fais une vache non
non c'est pas des princesses j'insiste
oh mais c'est facile ce jeu au palace
commence à être un peu plus violents non
je l'avais en assez scandaleux n'a pas
le temps
oui c'est bon un [ __ ] c'est de plus en
plus dur là on était ont été mis en mode
mignon quoi s'éclater elle non je
tournais au nom même le bâton le bâton
triple saut s'te plaît [ __ ] tu
détestais le magicien voilà et les
hurricanes qui vole on a réussi pas les
couilles savez ça quand c'est dur les
gars voilà extrêmement dur même
voilà je panique à je suis concentré
mais à la fois pas trop ça c'est bizarre
j'ai jamais été enceinte et à celui de
prendre ça mais pourquoi pourquoi on
n'embrasse pas le jury qui plus tard on
fait quoi
oh non non je suis aussi blaze exion
plus d'hommes chouette
ok on peut pas tout enchaîné on peut pas
toucher il faut temporiser voilà tel 1h
week end au maire je panique et je vous
avoue des bidons vérifie laissez moi
tranquille [ __ ] en plat oblats oui oh
ça va alors chouette ou là elle est une
source de problèmes oui un gros problème
oh [ __ ] mais le le bout tu piques de
l'est
ça fait du bien on aime les aveyronnais
revient en force on n'a pas le temps
mais oui mais qu'est ce que nul
attendait idée du siècle voilà allez oui
non monsieur chapron statu quo pas de
chapeau au sens premier chapeau [ __ ]
magicien en plus qu'est ce qui se passe
je veux que tu meurs tu meurs biot
voilà le saumon fumé pardon j'ai une
technique c'était pas ça ok laissez moi
le temps
c'était pas ça revient derrière derrière
j'ai technique de nage et était dingue
lie crois tu vas l'avoir et sa vache et
[ __ ] j'y crois pas mon gars à bientôt
je me tire à jeter tu es sopi passé
entre les deux si horrible e sur michel
pall attend fond ce dernier s'était très
vite
non la fais mon gars tu es sidi bou
qu'est-ce que tu regarde toi qui tu
regardes tes à choquer monga depuis 20
minutes
j'espère que quelqu'un trouvera la
princesse s'est promis y arriverons
[ __ ] [ __ ] popularité a grimpé à mais
on peut y arriver
oh oh oh oh
excuse moi c'était un jouet cement de
skill olala on est bon on est bon
regarder et banon
tu m'as petit coup de pression quand
même là pour ça que je le vois comme ça
d'un coup au regard des engrais comme
c'est faux trop tard mais c'est lui pour
une perturbation regard de pervers ah
non ça va pas ça passe
c'est une célébration nul de dôme salle
anouk et la corée à la difficulté réside
dans le parti rebond à mort fait les
fesses de magie sommet soit pas dit que
je ricane oui je d'arguer scharbook ait
gain est non facile si la voilà facile
[ __ ] on est là l affaire quoi mon gars
à je sais et sont mal à regarder
voilà niveau 18 on est mort que ce soit
cette fois se caille please
merci quétu je suis vieux mais oui mais
ça c'est facile à s'est pas fait peur
aux gt plus maître de rien regardez
regardez suis scandalisé de voir un tel
mépris
henri iv qui volent [ __ ] tu magicien
je suis pas magicien on trouvera la
princesse je vous le dis vous dire
regardez comme c'est beau mais oui j'en
mets chiale mais oui [ __ ] qui
s'appelle jean-michel ici ça va
jean-michel défis comme ça nulle âme et
sa meute or d'y arriver en regarder
suite sauté de sauter leur sauter ne pas
avancer de m'apprendre la clé nourrir
[ __ ] a choqué quand je m'en vais à
bientôt
je n'ai pas j'allais réussir j'ai réussi
c'est quoi ce bordel mec nickel alors à
ça ça me fait honte à ça va me rendre
dingue
hall a pas de fuite via la clé c'est bon
ou je me tire des six est bien trop
tendu pour moi un au revoir l'une nous
t'aimons ô salut assez méchant c'est lui
qui a une cape rouge et ou alors
peut-être pas c'est peut-être juste un
mec qui met sous la princesse mais qui
abandonna colonne
peut-être qu'il est moche alors texte
est pas une magicienne âge as tu es sûr
qu'il passerait pas
j'ai trouvé la technique voilà c'est de
tomber dans le vide et bien mourir comme
une merde c'est pas faute elle passe pas
au coeur petit chou et 4 nuls
info sauter avant on fait rire de mon il
arrive plutôt des comme ça tu parles et
humeur et un autre non je préfère le
vide
ab [ __ ] mais ça c'est compter sur un
mauvais effet à bombay stop stop on est
sûrement mais fine et très mauvais
feeling vous c'est la pire en dalles de
tout c'est elle est là elle sait
pourquoi puisque du coup tdp tu te
dépêches d y aller et quand tu
recommences tu énervé parce que futur
passe au dessus d'elle alors qu'elle
sert à rien non j'ai un bateau un chèque
ou pas je suis magicien pas sa dernière
moi je m'en bats les couilles de mourir
je m'en bats les couilles
oui on a doublé le nombre de morts sur
un niveau mais je m'en bats les steaks
j'ai pas le temps excusez moi je
pressais je dois les faire les courses à
bientôt
ah je croyais au alors là alors qu'elle
aille à me foutais osef
c'est vrai parti au yes
oh [ __ ] là j'étais sûr maintenant
moquin mini mais aucun [ __ ] mm hopla
n'abandonne pas acuité est si je pouvais
te mettre un gros coup de bâton bon tu
tombe dans le vide
il y avait trop peur je le ferai non oh
c'est tout con mais c'est tout dur comme
m'a dit non c'est bien claude coma j'ai
compris faire le doublé ce crime non non
non non non j'ai fait la technique
adéquat faut faire ça va pas pas du tout
pas du tout finalement bim bam boum drak
art dont j'étais prêt faute de mamadou
groupe a ha la la je suis pas bien là je
suis pas bien je commence à être pas
bien
regardez bien vous êtes choqués
attention voilà ouais j'suis croyez pas
vos expressions je t'aime comme un tour
à la nuque à attendez attendez attendez
attendez ça me fait plaisir mais ça ça
c'est vicieux ayant fait souche chapeau
son crâne il fait comme ça au bike c'est
pas possible
pourquoi je perds quoi s'attache
prochain pendant qu'on attendait ça fait
drôle que la même chose se met effet
deux claques doit quoi et bien pas elle
explose ou je tiens oui comme tu dis mon
amour quelle est cette sorcellerie
enragé crew on dira qu'on a eu on a eu
droit d'y croire du premier coup ah non
à chaque fois ils m'ont la trappe
affreux j'ai compris j'ai compris
regardez bien regardez bien attention là
on réussit tac tac tic tac
j'ai pas compris c'est le grand méchant
l'homme a bien rouge vient pistolet
devant nous tac presse space
o la princesse la princesse en fait des
gens ont trouvé la princesse il y a des
années elle était en train de dormir
mais attends attends tu vas quand même
ce pistolet qui déchire à ce que ça nous
rassure
j'suis là je peux plus bouger chez peak
et ils m'ont pétrifiée c'est comme ça
qu'il nous remercie nous on pétrifié on
est peut-être on répète rooney ou alors
on les prête noms nous nous sommes oui
mais voilà le cndd sur ce petit juge
avant une fin un jeu de plateforme un
petit peu compliqué c'est la première
l'une des premières fois qu'on réussit
[ __ ] bon écoute ou pas alors soit
c'est plus simple que d'habitude soit
pour ce qu'il s'est légèrement amélioré
ses besoins que d'habitude j'ai compris
je sois si vous a plus ces cas n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo comme d'habitude on se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo pour pas dire demain mais ça le
regarde et bon courage pour cette
dernière semaine de cours tu as tout le
monde pissas